vous le savez dans un instant on vous
parlera de ces démissions consacré au
père fouras avec le père fouras en axe
principal
il fera on n'y est pas de l sa bombe à
fouras moi j'ai comme j'ai dit ouais
faut parfois dans la région la bombarde
et fouras alors il vous compris par tout
le tournage en disant non enfin avez
vous écouté pouvait reformuler ils vont
tous les énoncés sous les pins dans
votre cas c'est un bon prennent une
autre dimension
merci beaucoup donc je vous rappelle que
les munitions qui va s'appeler qui va
kielwasser autour du père fouras qui est
boyard hollande avec un véritable par la
faction on a toutes les infos de même
des images devant les images de landreau
ça va se tourner et non à 40 km de paris
pour être précis merci est donc le père
fouras sera l' axe principal n'y aura
pas d'animateur ya pas de l'aider mais
il n'y aura que le père fois et donc on
s'est dit on a un père fouras au dépôt
d'avoir un père fouras
on a ailleurs dans l'émission est donc
on va tester donc les amener les
énarques du père super faire tester
alias gilles verdez est la première
équipe à tester le père fouras c'est
ludivine bernard montiel et cuisine qui
dit à léo malet
[Applaudissements]
gp on avait on n'avait même pas le
budget pour lui mettre un masque sur la
tête on lui a mis ses on avait rendu de
père noël qui traînait alors oui perdu
nos citoyens là va être un désastre
je savais que c'était une idée sans voix
tant de gens soient et pervers des
salles et si vous voulez me remonter
votre barbe mais bercy a lésé bayonne
écoutez le jeune hugo tu peux pas dire
si je suis à vos pieds
ce n'est pas pour vous les embrasser si
vous désirez me tirer c'est loin d'être
une preuve d'amour si je suis collé un
tas vous aurez envie de me dévorer à gc
je patinais sur un plateau de des pmp
nombreux sont ceux que vous allez
trouver
qui suis-je une houle non mais non
un maquereau nom donné par bernès un
boulet
j'aurais bien d'aller taper deuxième
équipe
magali berlin francesca et raymond
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon allez c'est bien vu pour la moule
bonne idée c'est une des deux séquences
encore les joli casting et couture et
vous écouter il vaut mieux en avoir et
tout mais certains n'ont aucun écho on
peut me jeter mais uniquement au sens
figuré
je suis tellement sensible que si l'on
me mets à toi je peux pleurer les bonnes
gens me on ne porte pas sa voix
je suis ouvert à ces matières mais un
dieu me suis fait
[Applaudissements]
philip lee 4 et valerie cruz miss aller
à lille d'un jardin on aime bien on est
mais on est quand même bien on est bien
allé benoît charlie anna et olivier
[Applaudissements]
millet et non pas il nous fallait une
équipe de vainqueurs écoutez je suis
devant vous mais pourtant personne ne me
reconnaît le son de ma voix est déformé
pour vous berner j'ai un grand nez et
pourtant je ne peux pas vous sentir qui
se nichent génie d olive il a une idée
allez fais toi plaisir il n'a rien
trouvé sa voie
bravo moins bon mais johann hay
[Applaudissements]